Narrator:
Tonight on "Shark Tank,"
tennis phenom
and accomplished entrepreneur
Maria Sharapova joins the Tank.
I make a lot of money
just being a spokesperson
and endorser of a brand.
Who's ready to get sweaty?
It's that time.
Dogs get tired of eating the
same thing over and over again.
Sharapova: Aww.
We've all got
that one special thing
that brings us right back
to our happy place.
I see dead people!
It is for up top, down there,
and everywhere in between.
Oh,
I have to punish you.
‐What a snake.
‐No, no.
‐Snake.
‐Maria's the devious one.
♪♪
Narrator: First into the Tank
is a stylish way to stay fit.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Natalie Holloway,
and this is my husband
and co‐founder, Max Kislevitz.
We're from Los Angeles,
California,
and we're seeking $400,000
in exchange for 10% equity
in our company.
Sharks,
you remember the '80s.
Aerobics
were all the rage.
And who could forget the wacky
fashion that came with it?
From headbands to leotards,
from leg warmers
to ‐‐ you guessed it ‐‐
wrist and ankle weights.
Mr. Wonderful,
I'm sure you remember it
like it was
just yesterday.
[ Imitating workout music ]
All right,
are you guys ready?
It's that time.
I know you're ready,
'cause I'm ready.
Oh, I'm gonna enjoy this.
Oh, yeah.
It's time to sweat.
I'm strong.
I'm strong, strong, strong,
strong, strong.
Nice!
‐[ Laughs ]
I'm late for my meeting.
Susan, hold my calls.
Nice!
[ Laughter ]
Great job, guys.
Great job!
Let's take five and cool off.
Nice.
[ Laughter ]
"Susan, hold my calls."
Sharks,
I am sure we can agree
that some trends were
better left in the past!
But of all the changes
over the last 40 years,
there's just one
that stayed the same ‐‐
the sweaty, loose, sand‐filled
wrist and ankle weight.
That is, until now!
Introducing...
Both: Bala Bangles!
The world's first...
Stylish...
Wearable weights.
Adding our weights
to your workout
will increase heart rate,
burn fat, and build muscle!
So, when you wiggle, there'll be
a little less jiggle.
Yeah.
So whether you're channeling
your inner yogi...
Or training for
that next marathon...
Bala Bangles will make you
sweat in style.
So, Sharks,
who's ready to get sweaty?
We will now pass out
some samples for you all to try,
and I'll show you
how to put them on.
So, what you're gonna want to
do, Velcro facing out,
and then you just roll down
like this and roll up.
The first time you do it,
it's a little tricky,
but then you're good.
As tight or loose
as you want.
And thank you, guys.
We can take it from here.
All right, guys.
Max:
So, our first product is
the 1‐pound wrist and ankle
weight that you guys have.
Bala is designed
to be additive
to a workout that is
already exhausting.
These are gonna make it
incrementally harder.
I know we're supposed to
ask you questions,
but when was the last time
that you worked out, Kevin?
Oh, shazam!
Excuse me, Maria.
I think that's very important
before ‐‐
You may want
to know this.
I got up at 4:30 this morning
to work out.
But I appreciate the fact
to be able to match my watchband
to this red weight.
I like that.
I like the outside texture,
as well.
You look spectacular.
You know what I really like
about these?
I like the fact that you don't
have to hold anything.
Yeah, and that's how it was
designed, actually.
I'm a certified
yoga instructor.
So, basically, it's hands‐free
so I can do yoga,
all of my poses, without
having to pick up dumbbells,
put them down,
and I can literally
do a whole class of yoga
and get that extra oomph.
Okay, guys,
you're asking for $400,000
for 10% of the company,
correct?
That's right.
That's correct.
So, what are your sales?
So, last year,
which was our first
six months in business,
we did $260,000.
Wow!
And then this year so far,
we're at $1.2 million.
‐$1.2 million?
‐Wow!
We'll end the year
with $2.2 million.
‐Whoa!
‐Good for you.
We just placed POs with
Bloomingdale's, Nordstrom.
So, we're 60% retail,
we're 30% Amazon,
we're 10% direct‐to‐consumer
through our website.
Our blended margin
is about 58.3% gross,
and we net about 49%.
Having said that,
our biggest challenge
and why we're here is,
we've been trapped in
this vicious inventory cycle.
It's been difficult for us to
keep the right level of product.
Yeah, inventory management
is always a pain.
Yep.
What does this retail at?
Well, landed, we're $12.
We can get that down.
Wholesale, we're $25,
and retail, we're $49.
Cuban: Good for you.
John: What are you gonna
use the money for?
Two key challenges.
The first is inventory, which
we spoke a little bit about.
The second is, we're not
out there proactively selling
because we're just trying to
keep up with the orders.
So we believe your capital
will help us
solve the inventory issue
and then to bring in
an external salesperson
to essentially blitz the market
so that nobody copies us.
Well, wait, wait, wait.
Why bring in another partner
right now?
I mean, you're gonna make
$2 million next year.
Because they need help
to market this thing.
Mm‐hmm.
Yeah.
Sharapova: If I were to
make this investment,
how do you see me
helping you?
Besides the money.
You bring a tremendous amount
of credibility to the product.
To have you
endorse this product,
you know,
there's no better supporter.
So you would see me as
a spokesperson for this product?
Yes. And you are
literally, like ‐‐
We looked at
your Instagram.
You're literally
our Bala customer.
O'Leary:
All right, guys, look.
I like it because it's got
fantastic numbers.
I'm gonna go at it
a different way.
You need capital for inventory.
It's a classic problem.
I'll give you the $400,000
as debt for three years, okay?
And I'm gonna charge you
7.5% interest on it.
I want 5% equity in the company
for doing this.
You get the benefit of
being in my ecosphere
of "Shark Tank" companies,
and you get Mr. Wonderful.
There's a lot of sports stars
and sports owners
and yada, yada, yada.
[ Laughs ]
But there's only one
Mr. Wonderful.
Sure. Thank you very much
for the offer.
[ Laughs ]
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
Well, it's a start,
let me tell you.
"Thank you very much
and buh‐bye."
Because you shouldn't
give up too much equity,
given the ramp you've got.
Let's hear
the other offers.
♪♪
Sharapova:
I like this a lot.
I think it fits
in my category very well.
I've actually been using
the 1‐ and 2‐pound weights
for my shoulder recovery
in the past year,
so I know all about it.
I like the look and feel of it.
I love your design.
I will make you an offer,
but I would like to bring in
another Shark with me.
I'll give you $200,000
if you can get another $200,000
from another Shark,
but 10%
is not enough for me.
Uh‐oh.
No disrespect to
anyone on this panel,
but I make a lot of money
just being a spokesperson
and endorser of a brand.
But I'm not going into this
just as that.
There's a lot more hustle that
I'll have to be delivering.
I would take...
30%.
♪♪
Narrator:
Max and Natalie have one offer
on the table from Kevin
for their wearable weights
company, Bala Bangles.
Maria is also interested,
but she wants to partner
with another Shark.
I would take 30%.
I would match that.
I would jump in there with her.
I will just share with you.
I really love it.
I'm just letting you know,
I would match that, as well.
I would match her offer.
I think these are fantastic.
Maria,
I will do it with you.
$200,000 from me,
$200,000 from you for 30%.
I just said
I'd go in with her.
You feel 30% is
the right offer.
But I have
the same proposal,
so I will take this out
internationally and...
I can blitz you into the stores
all over.
All over.
We can all do that.
O'Leary:
Maria, you threw out an offer ‐‐
you threw out an offer here,
and you said
you wanted another Shark.
You now have two Sharks fighting
to be your partner.
What did you decide, Mark?
What are you gonna do?
Would you be happy to go in
with another Shark?
I'm listening, right?
Okay.
Because I think you have to be
fair to them first and foremost.
Yep.
Kislevitz: We don't want to
erode the value of the company
below $3 million,
and we don't want to give up
more than 25%
unless two Sharks
were involved,
in which case,
we'd go up to 30%
because we understand
that you need
a big enough
piece of the pie
to sort of make sense
of the investment.
So you are saying
you'll part with 30% equity
if two Sharks
are involved?
At a $3 million valuation.
You want $900,000?
So each Shark has to put up
$450,000 to do your deal?
That's a big lift on your ask,
my friend.
That's huge.
Stop whispering over there,
Mark.
You're not in on this.
Yeah, and don't try to
throw me under the bus.
Don't try it, Mark.
I don't throw anybody
under the bus.
Maria, is Mark trying to
woo you away from me?
Sharapova: I think...
Is he? Is Mark trying to
woo you away from me?
Mark wants to
do a deal, as well.
From me.
I don't like that.
You know what?
I'm sorry ‐‐
I don't like that.
I'm gonna
make my own offer.
So, my offer is
$500,000, 18%.
♪♪
Cuban:
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait!
Okay, here's what
we'd like to do.
I agree with Maria.
She can take this
to the next level.
We haven't even discussed
globally yet,
and that's where, really,
she distinguishes herself
from anybody else
on the panel, right?
And because we both
believe in it,
if you believe in a company,
you don't nickel and dime
the cash down.
Don't let him take you.
You go all‐in.
And so
what we'd like to do ‐‐
Maria?
Yes.
Okay.
Don't let him take you!
What we'd like to do
is offer you the $900,000
for the 30% ‐‐
just what you asked for.
♪♪
You've got a deal.
Done.
‐Yes!
‐Aww!
Snake! Snakes!
We wanted
all of you guys.
Snakes!
Congratulations.
Thank you so much!
Snakes in the grass!
Thank you.
[ Laughs ]
♪♪
Well, I must say, it's the first
time in "Shark Tank" history...
I love that. I love it.
...I've actually seen Sharks
fight to be a partner.
What a snake.
Snake.
No, no, no,
Maria's the devious one.
Don't put it on me.
She gets all the credit.
I was fishing.
Ugh.
I can't believe it.
Aah!
[ Laughs ]
Having Maria and Mark
is a dream come true.
Having Maria, she's gonna
blow this up tomorrow.
She is our Bala girl.
We are so excited.
Maria is an icon ‐‐
a global icon.
She's gonna
make Bala explode.
I was born in Siberia.
My parents fled Belarus
because of Chernobyl
when my mother
was pregnant with me,
and when I was 2 years old,
we moved to the south of Russia,
to Sochi.
My parents were very young
when they had me.
My dad was working construction.
My mom was still in university.
My dad was very passionate
about sports,
and one day, when he went
to play some tennis,
I picked up a racket
and started hitting
against the wall by myself.
I went to a clinic when
I was 5 1/2 years old in Moscow
held by Martina Navratilova.
After the clinic,
she pulled my father aside
and said that I have
a great potential
to become a really good player
and that we should consider
moving to the United States.
The transition
to the United States
was incredibly tough.
My mom was left behind
because of visa issues,
so I didn't see her
for the first two years.
My dad was trying to find
local jobs here and there.
I barely knew any English,
and my dad even knew less
than I did.
When I was 14 years old,
I made my professional debut,
and that's when I started
playing with the big girls.
In 2004,
when I was just 17 years old,
I won my first Grand Slam,
which was Wimbledon.
There was a lot of
incredible opportunities
and endorsement deals
from pretty major companies.
I started to understand that
tennis wasn't just a game.
That was the first time
that I really got a sense
of the real business world.
In 2012, I decided to start my
candy company called Sugarpova.
I've had a sweet tooth ever
since I was a very young girl,
and I still very much do.
We need to continue being fun,
colorful, and flirty.
[ Chuckles ]
After being a small part
of many big brands,
I wanted to be the one in the
front office making decisions.
When you're in charge
of your own business,
it's a completely different
ballgame.
You're in charge
of the distribution,
you're in charge
of the creative,
of the people you hire,
and I really wanted
to make that step.
I like to invest in companies
that I'm personally
passionate about.
I invested in Supergoop,
a sunscreen brand that
I've loved for many years.
I invested in the UFC because
I saw its potential worldwide.
I like the attitude that
so many entrepreneurs have
that come on the show.
It's this "I won't give up
until I get what I want."
That is the American dream,
that there is no finish line
to what they do.
I had a very singular path
in my life
toward becoming
a successful athlete.
I wanted to achieve big things,
I had big goals,
and I still think
that there's more to achieve
on and off the court.
♪♪
Narrator:
Next into the Tank is a way
to spruce up a common meal.
♪♪
Hey, Sharks. I'm Brett.
And I'm AJ.
And we're seeking $100,000 in
exchange for 20% of our company.
Sharks, would you enjoy eating
the same thing every single day?
Of course you wouldn't.
And dogs don't like it, either.
That's why
AJ and I created
Shake it Pup!
dog food seasoning.
Dogs get tired of eating the
same thing over and over again.
And with
such limited diets,
they miss out on
important nutrients.
But don't take
our word for it.
Just ask Chef Cooper.
‐Aww!
‐Hey, Coop.
Do you like eating the same
boring food every single day?
We're shaking up and waking up
the dog food industry.
With Shake it Pup!,
our furry family members
can now enjoy a humanlike
mealtime experience,
with a new feast to look
forward to every single day.
But what does it take?
It takes...
just one shake
to turn that bland dog food
into a filet mignon.
You'll be your dog's
personal gourmet chef
with just the shake
of a bottle.
Chef Cooper, what's on
tonight's main course?
[ Laughter ]
Pizza it is.
Our handcrafted,
all‐natural recipes
allows pup parents
to tailor their meals
directly to their dog's
unique tastes
and nutritional
requirements.
[ Laughter ]
There's a seasoning for
every reason and every season.
Sharks, with your help, we'll be
able to streamline production
and take a bite out of
the dog food industry.
So, who's ready
to shake hands
and shake...
It...
Both: ...Pup?
[ Laughter ]
Chef Cooper
does have samples
for all of you, as well.
‐Come here. Hi. Hi, baby.
‐Aww.
‐Hi!
John: Hey!
Here.
Thank you, sir.
‐You're welcome.
‐Mr. Wonderful.
‐Thank you very much.
‐You are welcome.
And it's all human‐grade,
all local and organic
ingredients and natural.
This is just a seasoning,
right?
So it goes on top of all
the food that we serve?
Correct. So, compared to
a lot of toppers,
if you put
a freeze‐dried topper,
or meat, for example,
dogs just pick it out.
They eat around it.
We always make the joke that,
you know, dogs are like kids ‐‐
they eat the marshmallows
in cereal
and leave
everything else.
What we do
completely coats the food
so it adds a whole new
flavor profile,
and you're able to
mix up meals
without changing their diet
completely.
What else is out there
that's comparable?
Our main competitors are wet
foods that we find, and then,
as well as freeze‐dried
toppers, meat‐based.
Well, then let's get into
the numbers. Prove it out.
Yeah, how long have you
been in business?
Okay, so, in the first
annual year ‐‐
We launched a little over
a year ago,
and in the last annual year,
we've done $105,000 in sales.
Initially,
when we launched,
we were still producing this
in‐house.
It's a 350‐square‐foot
headquarters,
my living facilities,
and our production facilities.
So, we grew really fast.
We found traction right away.
We got in my truck
and drove to every store
and venue in California.
But we ran into production
issues right away.
Okay.
And we became
very agile ‐‐
In other words,
you sold out.
And we sold out.
You don't
have a copacker yet.
We don't have a copacker.
Are you still
in that same apartment?
Yes.
So, we actually have invested
everything we've made
back into small equipment,
production equipment.
But we're not production guys.
We're not manufacturing guys.
Greiner: Right.
We've done this
out of necessity.
How much are these selling for,
each unit?
Sure.
So, on average, about $2.45
is our cost to make them,
and they sell for $12.99.
‐Good for you.
‐What?
‐Wow.
‐$13?
‐We knew you'd like that.
Yeah, that was ‐‐ And each
bottle lasts 30 to 60 meals.
You're not saying a lot.
What do you do in the company?
I know, because, obviously,
he speaks so well,
and he knows he's on top
of everything,
so I just got to kind of
let him go with it.
What is your background?
Yeah, of course.
Like any good story, we've been
best friends since second grade,
and we met
on the school bus,
and our friendship has kind of
always revolved around dogs.
The very first moment
I met him ‐‐
Sounds so romantic.
I know.
[ Laughter ]
‐Oh, Lord.
‐It's not.
It's not romantic.
Don't worry.
I was on the school bus,
and my dog at that time, Bailey,
wasn't doing too well,
and on the way home,
I just had the sense
that Bailey died.
And I started crying
on the bus,
and Brett was sitting
in the seat behind me,
peeks his head over and asks,
"Why are you crying?"
We start talking.
He tells me about his dogs,
Maddy and Buddy,
and here we are today.
Okay, so, let's get back
to business.
Okay.
All right.
So, the challenge
is capital.
Every company's gonna
go through that.
"If I only had more money,
I could reach everybody."
Right.
But there's a point of
diminishing returns.
Sure.
So, tell us about
your inventory right now.
So, right now, we have
about 3,000 bottles,
and that's about
a month and a half's
supply for us.
Essentially, we are ordering
when we get the POs.
O'Leary: Have you gone
and investigated any copackers
in the spice space,
for example?
We have, and we know
the minimums
are gonna be
about 3,000 bottles per SKU.
Okay.
And we're still narrowing down
the actual price per ‐‐
Give me a range.
That would drop our costs
down to close to $2.
What do you need us for?
We cannot produce this
ourselves anymore.
We need a partner.
So, right now, we pay ‐‐
37% of our costs are packaging
and labeling,
which is astronomical
because we don't have
any purchasing power.
Over the last decade
of "Shark Tank,"
I have seen every crazy
doggy idea and then more.
And every single one of them
goes through the roof
when people see ‐‐
It's sick.
It's so crazy how much money
people spend on dogs.
So I'm converted, okay?
I get it. I get it.
I think this idea is nuts,
but I know it's gonna work,
because I look at dogs
eating kibble saying,
"That must be
boring as hell."
And a little pizza,
or whatever it is,
it's interesting, but it's
a massive marketing problem.
I think it's a nightmare.
You guys are just so early.
Why do you think
it's a marketing problem?
Because no one knows
about this, and ‐‐
Exactly ‐‐
that's the beauty of it,
is so many people know
about so many things.
Yeah, I get it.
This is new.
It's so early.
I'm willing to
make you an offer.
Here it is.
It reflects the risk.
But I don't have a doggy do‐do
in my portfolio right now.
Says the man who's like,
"This is nuts, and I
don't see it working."
Kevin always talks up the risks
so he can undercut his offer.
O'Leary: Of course.
Yeah.
It's better than nothing.
Do you want to hear it or not?
So, silence from
the doggy gallery.
Well, I do, so...
I am going to make an offer.
Here it is.
I'm gonna give you
the $100,000,
but commensurate with
how early‐stage you are
and the nightmare of ‐‐
I bet he's gonna ask
for a royalty.
Silence, please.
[ Laughs ]
I want 50%.
‐Oh!
‐[ Laughing ] Ohh!
That's worse!
Kevin!
That's worse.
Lots of noise.
I hear lots of noise.
I don't hear any offers.
I hear noise.
Greiner:
You're gonna get what?
I hear ‐‐ I hear
doggies barking.
What is that?
Doggies barking.
I want 50%.
What do you say?
Uh...
[ Laughter ]
I'm gonna have to
feel out the room
and see if there are
some other offers.
O'Leary: You know,
you really should,
because if you don't get
anything else,
all roads go back to
Mr. Wonderful, as usual.
Maybe I can help you
with a decision.
You know, I think
it's a genius idea,
but I think that this is
a speed‐to‐market thing
that you have to do,
and I think that,
honestly, a lot of
the big boys and girls,
they're going to start putting
a lot of these offerings in,
and it's gonna be
a challenge to fight that.
And so I'm out.
Maiolfi: And to speak to that ‐‐
Thank you, Daymond.
But as far as
dog food companies,
we were in that industry.
We speak with
a lot of the big boys.
They won't touch any toppers or
enhancers with a 10‐foot pole.
They don't want to touch it
because what does that say
about their dog food?
Yeah, this isn't something
you want to release
with a dog food
manufacturer.
‐Yeah.
‐Right?
Sounds like
your biggest inhibitor
has just been
your ability to make it.
Right.
You have more demand than
you can fulfill right now.
Right.
Sharapova: I'm gonna
go ahead and say it.
I love your brand.
I love your marketing.
I love the category
that you're in.
There's a lot of opportunity,
but I also feel
that it's very crowded,
and this is very niche.
This is, like,
a second‐step process.
So, to feel like I have to
get another something
to put on the food that
I already put on the plate
just seems like a lot,
and for that reason,
I'm out.
So, I think this is
really interesting,
'cause I do know people
that have dogs that are
very, very picky.
I don't know for sure ‐‐
I haven't been able
to test this ‐‐
but I think
people love their dogs,
and I think they would
like their dogs
to have
a more fun life experience.
So why not
make your dog's food better?
Maybe you could make cat food
better, too, right?
Rabbit food?
I mean, if it works, it could
become a line of something.
So I like
everything about it.
So, I'm gonna give you
the $100,000.
You have a lot of margin
here in your product, okay?
I'm gonna ask
for $1 per unit
until I get
the $100,000 back.
Then I'll go down
to 25 cents a unit.
John: Oh.
In perpetuity.
Forever and ever.
I would never do
that deal.
[ Laughs ]
But I'm only asking
for 3% equity.
That's it.
I'm not gonna be a 20% partner.
John: "Only."
You know, I'm the king of
royalties, and I know when
you can extract money.
3% of the company leaves you
with your company.
You can't afford it.
You don't have enough capital
to do that.
Well,
I'm giving them capital.
It makes no sense.
And then,
if we're doing fabulously,
I'll continue to bankroll
the purchase orders.
But those are two offers.
What are you gonna do,
Mark?
Cuban: So, last year,
I did a deal with a company
called Wild Earth
that does organic dog food.
Wild Earth has been
a great success
because dog owners really care
about their pet health,
and they will spend anything
to do it the right way.
I think this would be
a great combination.
I'm not asking for a royalty,
but I do want equity, right?
Because I think
this can grow,
and I think that's where
the upside is.
So I'll offer you $100,000
for 25% equity.
Maiolfi: Um...
Well, let us talk to Cooper
about this first.
Oh, what,
you got to talk about it?
‐Aww.
I think
we have a deal.
Done.
Appreciate it, guys.
Looking forward to it.
Thank you.
Appreciate it, guys.
And you, too!
Yeah! We'll do some business
and make you some money!
Greiner: Sweet dog.
Thanks, guys.
Thank you for your time.
Sharapova: Thank you very much.
Good luck.
Good presentation.
Thank you.
[ Squeals ]
Whoo!
Maiolfi: We were in
our 350‐square‐foot studio,
and then today, to shake hands
with Mark Cuban
and have him on as a partner
is just insane to us.
Come here!
We did it!
♪♪
Narrator:
Next up is a business that hopes
to bring people together.
[ Chuckles ]
Aah!
[ Laughter ]
My name's Michael.
And my name is Eugene.
We're brothers from
Portland, Oregon,
and we're here
to raise $500,000
for 10% of our company,
Pips & Bounce.
Sharks, we've all got
that one special thing
that brings us right back
to our happy place.
For us,
it's ping pong.
We grew up playing
a never‐ending game
in our basement rec room
in Appalachian Kentucky.
Where I pretty much went
undefeated against this guy.
Well, after we grew up
and realized just how
disconnected we all had become,
we went back
to our fondest memories
and created...
Pips & Bounce.
A unique ping pong social club
inspired by our childhood fun.
A gathering place where everyone
can get together
to eat, drink,
and ping some pong.
Complete with 100% authentic
oak‐paneled walls,
great tunes,
and throwback posters.
Mark, looking good.
[ Laughter ]
That was last week.
[ Chuckles ]
Sharks, it's now time
to franchise.
Folks from all over have been
asking us to give them a way
to bring the fun of
Pips & Bounce home with them.
So, Sharks, we invite you
to enjoy one of
our signature pong‐tails
and join us as we create
a new family
of pong‐trepreneurs
together with Pips & Bounce.
Both: Who's in?
So, there must be
a profitable business here
if you want
to franchise it.
Why don't you walk us through
the numbers?
So, in our last three
fiscal years,
we started off with $974,000
in revenue,
and then the next year,
we pulled in $1.33 million.
The year after that,
$950,000.
So, we're kind of flat.
All right.
How many square feet
is the place?
Our first store
is 4,500 square feet.
So, if you're trying
to sell me a franchise,
you could make a claim
that you make at least, you
know, 1 million bucks a year.
What do you bring
in the bottom line
in the typical operation
of 4,500 square feet?
We're at
a 7% profit margin.
We've been building it
with this goal of
franchising it in mind.
And what was your history
prior to this?
I was in New York City.
I was doing business development
and marketing
for a big
international law firm.
Now,
what's your background?
So, I spend my days
saving the world
through
clean‐energy policy.
[ Chuckles ]
But I spend my nights
and weekends
trying to bring people together
through the joy of ping pong.
O'Leary: Let's go back
to the business for a second,
because I invest in
franchise models.
I'm pretty familiar
with how it works.
You're making $1 million.
Let's keep the numbers even,
all right?
Okay.
You're making
7% for yourself.
$70,000 is being extracted
from the business
on the million‐dollar model.
Now, in the franchise
business,
you want to get a royalty of 5%
to 7% for every one you sell.
So the business has to make
a minimum of 14% pre‐tax.
The person that franchises
from you
is gonna pay you maybe $25,000
or $50,000 up front
to get all of your knowledge
on how to set it up.
So it's got to make 14%
year‐in, year‐out.
Otherwise, there's no incentive
for them to do this.
You're nowhere near that yet.
You have to get
all that worked out
so that I am so interested
in doing this
that it's made easy for me.
I write you the $25,000
so my 10 tables arrive,
my paddles arrive,
my balls arrive.
So, you're saying
you could do it on your own?
This just put me
to sleep.
No, I'm not.
I'm just saying ‐‐
He's right, though.
He's exactly right.
It's not gonna work.
It's not franchisable yet.
No, the numbers ‐‐
Okay, not only that ‐‐
Do you have
more than one unit yet?
So, we had just signed a lease
for our second unit.
That's gonna be going up in
Minneapolis, Minnesota.
Did you franchise it?
Do you guys own it?
This is
a corporate location.
What capital did you have to
spend to set it up? How much?
We're setting that up
with a $1 million budget.
A $1 million budget?
Yes.
So, we're building our second
location to be a showroom,
a flagship, a training center
for our franchisees.
We're not building this
as the cookie‐cutter
and that'll go out.
Exactly, guys.
And that's a big part
of the point. You're too early.
You haven't proved
that you can run
a multi‐unit environment
yet,
you haven't proved that
you can make enough money
to support a franchise fee
and make enough money for
an owner to get a return on it.
So for those reasons,
I'm out.
John: Okay, guys.
I love the story,
I love the drink,
I hate ping pong.
I'm out.
[ Both chuckle ]
O'Leary: Wow.
Thank you, Daymond.
Thank you.
Thanks for the drink,
though.
You know, honestly,
I love ping pong.
I think it's really fun.
But I agree with Kevin.
I think
it's way too early.
I wish you the best,
but I'm out.
Michael:
Well, it seems early to you,
but all of you
are entrepreneurs.
You've all
built businesses.
You all had to say yes to things
that you weren't yet ready for.
You all had to take
that leap of faith.
Yeah.
Cuban: But you do that
as an entrepreneur,
not necessarily
as an investor.
That's the challenge.
It's not that we don't
think you can do it.
But you haven't shown
that it's replicable yet.
Basically, you're telling me
I got to spend $1 million ‐‐
that's what you're doing
on your store.
The million is for the showroom,
the flagship.
I know, but that's
a really bad showroom.
It shows me
it's a bad franchise.
It's bigger than what it needs
to be because we're gonna be
training our franchisees.
Well,
why are you doing that?
And what we're doing is,
we're trying to bring
people together.
You have to tell me
as a franchisee
I'm gonna make 20% on it.
Now I'm interested
in Pips & Bounce.
But you're not telling me
that at all.
You don't have that model
worked out yet.
Guys, the numbers
are very, very bad.
Not weak, but terrible.
Sharapova: I'm intrigued.
I like the concept
of going somewhere
and not just
going there to eat.
I like the activity element.
I mean, you see the ice cream
museum doing experiences,
you see the escape rooms,
so people are paying for that.
It's definitely
a proof of concept.
But I wish there was
a little bit more there.
Sorry ‐‐ I'm out.
So, think about it this way.
Ping pong has been around for ‐‐
How much of your own money
have you put into this?
So, we've bet every dollar
that we have.
How much is that?
We put in $300,000.
And why do you think
it's worth $5 million today?
The way we look at it is,
over 100 units,
which is a conservative estimate
over the 150 units
of metropolitan statistical
areas we can address ‐‐
But you have one unit.
We're valuing
the franchise business.
We're not valuing
our unit.
Oh, I have to punish you.
I have to punish you.
[ Laughter ]
I knew that was coming.
I'm holding back.
That's a big, big step forward,
yeah.
Please hold me back!
We look at a net present value
of over $100,000 per location.
[ Laughs ]
Guys, come on.
Mark, what would you approach
our valuation at?
What is it worth, and how can we
grow this together?
You're not ready
to franchise.
If you and I invest
in Pips & Bounce
to start off
the whole thing, right,
and you said, "Mark,
should we franchise yet?" ‐‐
you know what my answer
would be?
Hell no!
'Cause you're not
ready yet.
[ Laughs ]
So if one of my friends
came to me and said,
"Mark, Pips & Bounce,
you're an investor, right?
You love the place.
We went there.
We had so much fun!
Should I buy a franchise?" ‐‐
you know what
my answer would be?
Tell them, Maria.
Hell no!
Exactly.
Only, I'd be louder.
[ Laughs ]
You get my point.
O'Leary:
What's it worth to buy out
$70,000 cash flow
from a retail operator?
Probably four
or five times that.
That's all you're worth.
So you're miles from
5 million bucks.
Presentation was horrible.
You're nice guys.
I hate this a lot.
I'm out.
[ Cuban laughs ]
Well, you know, look ‐‐
I think we're all out,
guys.
Thanks, guys.
Thank you.
‐Yeah. Good luck, guys.
‐Thank you.
I hate ping pong, and now
I hate ping pong players.
[ Laughs ]
Wow.
Michael:
You know, if we can count
every time
someone said no to us ‐‐
every bank,
every investor,
every accountant
who said no to us ‐‐
we wouldn't be here.
What, five more nos?
We can take it.
Yeah.
♪♪
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is a product line
for a usually neglected area.
♪♪
Hello, Sharks.
My name is Laura Schubert.
And I'm Lillian Tung.
We're here
from New York City
seeking $500,000
for 2.5% equity in our company.
‐What?!
‐Whew!
‐I see dead people!
[ Laughs ]
Now, Sharks, we all know
that hairstyles change
over the years.
But I'm not just talking about
the hair on your head.
We're also talking about...
Both: Pubic hair!
Wait.
Can we say that on TV?
I don't know,
but I guess we just did.
We're here to tell you that no
matter what your preference is,
it's great to embrace
whatever you're into.
Let's say you're anything
like our friend Bo.
She likes to keep her hair
full and bushy.
Come on out, Bo.
Uh‐oh.
‐Oh.
‐[ Laughs ]
Aww. Aww.
Similar to Bo,
some people like to keep
their hair full‐grown,
keeping their silky locks
or curls
all natural
and feeling free.
Or if you're like
our friend Peep,
summertime means keeping things
sleek and shaven.
There's conditioner
for head hair...
[ Laughter ]
...lotions for your bodies, and
even serums to keep acne away.
So, tell me, why is there
nothing for pubic hair?
Well, Sharks,
that's where we come in.
Thanks, Bo and Peep.
We'll take it from here.
Aww.
[ Sheep bleats ]
Both: Introducing Fur!
The first line of all‐natural
and effective skin and hair care
for up top, down there,
and everywhere in between.
So, whether you think
the bush is back or skin is in,
Fur is here to take care of
your body in an upscale way.
Sharks,
we are on a mission
to destroy the taboo
around pubic hair.
Both: So, tell us,
who's with us?
[ Chuckles ]
And we have samples.
‐Okay.
‐All right.
Well...
It's an interesting product.
Daymond.
Thank you.
Lori.
Thanks, Mr. Wonderful.
I don't want the same
hair product as Kevin.
[ Laughter ]
You don't need the same
hair product I have.
Nice suit.
Cuban: The best part
is, there's towels.
Thank you.
[ Laughter ]
‐Pretty bottle.
‐And for you.
Thank you, ma'am.
Thank you. Yes.
Appreciate it.
Thanks.
Schubert:
So, in front of you,
you have our signature product,
Fur Oil.
This really put us
on the map in 2017
when a major celebrity endorsed
it completely organically.
We actually sold out
of all of our stock
for an entire year
in only three weeks.
Who was it
that promoted it?
Emma Watson.
Then we also selected a product
from our line for each of you.
For Mark and Kevin,
we selected the Stubble Cream,
which is a great hit among men,
especially as an aftershave.
For Maria and Daymond, we chose
the Ingrown Concentrate,
which is our best‐selling
ingrown hair serum.
And for Lori,
the luxurious Silk Scrub.
Sharapova: Smells great.
But to break into this market,
you needed a hook.
I get it ‐‐ you went with
the pubic thing. Cool.
Greiner: Was that your hook?
But you must have
some extraordinary sales
to walk in here and say
that I'm gonna give you
$500,000 for 2.5%,
imputing
a $20 million valuation.
Bring it on!
John:
Before you answer that,
why would somebody
want to oil up ‐‐
or oil down ‐‐
their pubic hair?
Cuban: Daymond,
how can you even ask that?
[ Laughter ]
I just want to know
why you ‐‐ you know,
somebody would
want to do that.
Everyone's suffered from
razor burn, ingrown hairs.
If you treat your pubic hair
and your body hair
like your head hair,
like your face,
you don't even
get ingrown hairs anymore.
It softens the hair
and clears your ‐‐
Even if you wax?
Absolutely.
Waxing salons and spas are some
of our very best customers.
Why hasn't somebody else
done something like this?
It's a taboo category,
and no one's really taken it on
in an upscale, elevated way
that treats it
as a serious problem.
Cuban:
And that's the key, 'cause
there are some men's products,
but they're more
barbershop‐type products,
none that are
on the higher end.
Tell us a little bit
about your background.
I've spent years at L'Oréal
developing makeup
and being in
the beauty industry.
Laura has spent 10 years
in corporate America,
most recently as
a management consultant.
So, I've been working on Fur
since 2014.
I wanted the solution myself,
and I just knew
that other women and men
wanted options like I did
to take care of
their hair and skin.
We have created
an entirely new category here.
I have to admit, you're sounding
less crazy by the minute.
[ Chuckles ] Thank you.
Well, thank you.
'Cause you started
at crazy factor 110.
Well, it's not crazy, right?
There's an opportunity there.
How much have you guys
put in yourselves,
and how much have you raised,
and do you have any debt?
We've put in $500,000
into the business...
‐Whoa!
‐Good for you.
...between the two of us.
That's all‐in.
We are all‐in.
That's our life savings.
It's our life savings.
We have no other investors.
Good for you guys.
And no debt.
No other investors
and no debt.
Okay, now I'm getting
really interested.
What are the sales
of Fur?
We're on track
to do $5 million this year.
Cuban: Good for you guys.
And what is
most of your sales?
Is it the oil
or the other products?
No, it's actually around
the whole product line.
O'Leary: Why don't you walk us
through your margins?
Yeah.
Sure.
For the Fur Oil,
it's $46,
and it costs us
$5.34 to make it.
‐I love this business.
‐Wow.
And the other products?
On average,
our line is $37,
and $7.63 is our average
fully absorbed.
Have I told you
how much I love it?
[ Laughs ]
Those margins are obscene.
Where are we year‐to‐date,
just so ‐‐
They did $535,000
last month.
"We." Notice he said,
"Where are we?"
I'm all about
the nether regions.
$3.5 million year‐to‐date.
Tung: And we haven't
hit holiday yet.
That's pretty good.
Now, valuation, ladies.
$500,000 for 2.5%.
I don't get out of bed to do
anything with my nether regions
for 2.5%.
Well,
in the beauty industry ‐‐
You must have flexibility.
In the beauty industry,
it's common
for companies to sell for
four to six times revenue.
Guys, congratulations on what
you've done so far, right?
Thank you.
I love the confidence
that you have
'cause you know
it's going to happen, right?
But it's not really
a fit for me,
but I don't have
any doubt in my mind
that you're gonna be
insanely successful.
So congrats,
but for those reasons, I'm out.
Okay,
thank you very much.
Understood.
You're welcome.
What's the model?
Have you considered licensing?
Because you can get people
to use their money
and distribution,
get it to a nice level,
a 3‐year, a 5‐year license,
and then still have
the opportunity to sell.
Hell no. Hell no.
‐No. No way.
‐Why not?
Why?
They're killing it!
Greiner: They don't need to.
And it's
a mission‐based brand.
We need to own the branding
and the authenticity.
Listen, I would give you
the $500,000 for 15%.
Thank you very much
for that offer.
Uh...
Wow, you girls
aren't fooling around.
[ Laughs ]
Why should they?
Does that mean yes?
O'Leary: Well, while
you're thinking about that,
let me throw something
on the table,
because I am really impressed,
all right?
Oh, here we go.
Because my creative juices
are flowing.
Oh, no, she's already...
[ Laughter ]
We're ready.
♪♪
Narrator: One Shark is out.
Laura and Lillian have one offer
on the table from Daymond
for their body hair care line,
Fur.
But Kevin also seems interested.
O'Leary:
So, I'll give you the $500,000,
but your margins are
obscenely wonderful.
There's plenty of space
in here...
For a royalty.
...to give me $1 per bottle
per SKU
until I get back $1 million.
Then it stops, goes away.
And I want the 2.5% equity
so I have some skin in the game.
I'll do that deal
right now with you.
Thank you very much
for that offer.
It's a great offer.
Let's be ‐‐ you're not
the best spokesperson for this.
I'm a fantastic
spokesperson.
[ Laughs ]
I think it's interesting,
but you said that
you have a mission.
What exactly
is your mission?
We want everyone
to feel comfortable
with their body hair
expressions,
whatever they may be,
and we are trying to ultimately
increase body positivity
and acceptance,
you know, for the future.
So,
that's the bigger thing.
Exactly.
The whole mission is really
more about feeling good
about yourself.
Yes.
So, let me present
something to you, okay?
I will give you $500,000.
I want 12%.
And why don't we say
that we will take
in the first year $50,000
and put it towards a charity
that will help
to start putting the message
out there
for people to feel better
about their body,
no matter how big, how small,
how hairy, or whatever.
O'Leary: What do you want to do?
You have three offers.
But we may have one
from Maria.
Yes, no?
I like the space.
I invested in Supergoop,
which is a sunscreen brand,
after being a fan
and using the product,
finding it on the shelves
of Sephora,
and became an investor
a few years ago.
But 2.5% is really nothing.
Um...I feel like I would need
so much more skin in the game
just to feel passionate about
what I'm involved with.
There's a lot of work.
2.5% is just ‐‐
it's not enough.
So I'm out.
Whoa.
Okay, thank you
for your candid feedback.
You have three offers.
What are you gonna do?
Well, thank you all for
your offers, first of all.
And?
Would any of you
do $500,000 for 5%?
I would not.
I wouldn't, either.
Daymond?
No. I can't do it at 5%.
I will go to 10%. I will go down
to 10% from 15%.
You clearly don't want
to give up equity.
You understand my offer,
don't you?
Listen, I offered you what
I thought was my best offer.
I mean, we love the angle,
the charity angle,
so thank you very much
for being so creative with that.
I know that I can help you
blow up fast,
but it has to mean something
to me, as well.
Every Shark's gonna tell you
the same thing.
We should get to
the endgame here.
I think Daymond's
sitting around 10%, right?
Yeah, but...
You know,
sometimes it's gut feeling.
I think you are
both brilliant, but...
I'm starting not to think that
we would be good partners,
'cause I don't think
they understand the value,
so I'm just going to
take my deal off the table,
my offer off the table.
I'm out.
♪♪
You guys, what were you thinking
when you walked in here?
Cuban: They moved to 5%.
No, we were hoping
for the 5%.
Okay, so, I love your margins,
I love your business,
I love what you've done,
but I'm an investor.
[ Greiner laughs ]
I'm an investor.
Do you have any flexibility
past 5%?
Show us
something creative back.
'Cause I think
we're at the end of the road.
We could go higher
for more money.
No. That's
the same problem, right?
[ Both chuckle ]
♪♪
Should we just ‐‐
Is that it, then?
All right, I'm gonna
leave it right on this line.
I would do $500,000 for 8%
and $50,000 towards
a charitable component.
What do you think,
Lillian?
All right,
I think we have a deal.
We have a deal.
Done! Whoa!
John: There you go.
Yay!
‐Congrats.
‐Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Congrats.
You did a great job,
you guys.
We look forward to
working with you.
‐Congrats, guys.
‐And good luck to you.
‐Thank you.
‐Good luck.
Well, I didn't plan
on this today.
[ Laughs ]
No, definitely not.
Tung:
With Lori now on our side,
it strengthens the mission,
brings it to the masses.
That charitable component ‐‐
which is also, again,
mission‐driven ‐‐
is really
just gonna bolster
what we stand for
and what we believe in.
♪♪